[Music]
It's kind of like the boat rowing. Do
you see?
>> It's kind of like it. So, he's driving,
right? And I had to have that turn. Do
you see?
>> And that part is where Whoa. Oh, cuz
that is not where my bracing angle is.
Do you see that? But if I am shifting
weight properly, that doesn't matter.
>> Do you see? This doesn't matter. And
then this part is easy. Okay. Once you
get there,
but getting there is the hard part.
Okay. Um,
can you see that? Let's do it from this
angle.
Okay.
So
here you can kind of get that bracing
angle. Do you see? Okay. But once you
come here, there's no there's no bracing
angle anymore. There's only ground
vectoring and then this turns.
Okay. So then it's just
boom.
Okay.
>> Okay. So pay attention to that. And I
would do the same thing
rel as you release the muscle tension at
the earliest sensation of it you're
going to be more successful then you try
to release it where now it's
structurally dependent. Do you get it?
The same it's the same exact thing
as you start to feel that rather than
flexing and try to hold it longer
because there's no you can't hold it
here. Do you see this energy is going
here and this bracing angle is off to
the side. Okay. So, as you starting to
feel it, oh, I can feel Oh, that release
that calf tension. Release it. Let all
that drop. Okay.
>> All right. Shy.